only on CBS this morning Democratic
senator Cory Booker of New Jersey is
with us from Capitol Hill he's a member
of the Senate Judiciary Committee which
is investigating Russian interference in
the 2016 election senator good morning
let's start with this report about the
president so he was worried about a
conflict of interest and but the fact is
he didn't fire Muller so why is this a
big deal well it's a big deal because
that effort or that thought about doing
so would really plunge our country into
a constitutional crisis to fire the
special prosecutor especially after the
fact pattern we're seeing about the
firing of the FBI director really
presents a problem for our nation as a
whole to have an unaccountable president
undermining actively undermining an
ongoing investigation into his
administration and his campaign where a
number of close allies and associates
have already faced indictment and have
already faced serious levels of
investigation well if he didn't do
anything you at one point had worked
with Lindsey Graham to protect the
special counsel are you gonna renew your
effort to put forward legislation that
would do that well we've been persistent
on our efforts we have a lot of
bipartisan support for it even the fact
that chuck Grassley would hold a hearing
on this legislation the reality is is we
are in a position right now where should
the president order the firing of the
special prosecutor we really have no
check or balance on his power this is
something that is clearly needed right
now and frankly it's something that I
think would be needed in future
generations so that there would be an
independent overview of the president's
power to remove a special prosecutor and
and you have to understand right now
there is no check there's no
presidential accountability and we
believe that should lie with the
judiciary and so right we have a
president who has shown his tendencies
to do things in what I believe are an
authoritarian and anti-democratic manner
and we need to make sure we ensure what
the founders of our nation really
designed a series of checks and balances
so that the power of the presidency
doesn't really undermine
the sanctity in many ways of the
Republican that the president themselves
is not above the law one of the things
he was apparently concerned about was a
possible conflict of interest because
Robert Muller he says and James Comey
our friends does he does he have a point
no I mean I you what you have seen it is
okay that we are hearing now that the
President had intended to fire the
special prosecutor in addition to that
now we've seen a great pattern amongst
Republicans especially House Republicans
as well as the White House to try to
undermine the integrity of someone that
when they were announced there was
unanimity in fact it was a quieting that
was happened in Congress because of the
respect of this person but yet we've
seen these persistent attacks to try to
undermine the credibility to try to
undermine the work and that to me is
unacceptable this is somebody who has
shown not only their ability and the
capacity to do this investigation in an
independent way with consistent
integrity but to do so again also shakes
people's faith in our institutions and
so we should let the special prosecutor
do their job and we should preserve
their independence by putting in checks
and balances like the legislation
proposed by me and Lindsey Graham well
it seems the president's gonna go along
and talk about special counsels so maybe
that threat has passed let me ask you a
question about immigration senator the
president has put forward a bill
increasing the number of dreamers who
would be able to stay in the United
States why not take that well again most
of us would take that if it stood alone
that that we have a pathway to
citizenship for these folks who are
American citizens in every single way
except for a piece of paper they served
in our military it pledged allegiance to
our Flags they've taught in our schools
or entrepreneurs they're creating jobs
and so what is offensive about the
president's proposal is he wants to put
tens of billions of dollars at a time
that our country is screaming for
infrastructure investment that many of
the best experts on homeland security do
not believe we need this is like money
for 19th century technology at a time
that we could use 21st century
technology less expensive to protect our
borders there's not a senator in
Congress that doesn't want secure
borders but the way this prize
going about it seems to be more about a
campaign promise and campaign rhetoric
than what's best to secure this country
and to use dreamers again fellow
Americans in every way Bella for only 10
billion dollars for the for the wall I
just want to finish my sentence to use
them as a political pawn right now is to
me reprehensible when everyone knows
these kids right now are suffering
they're in severe anxiety that's up
ending their education and their work
and so I don't want to back myself into
a use this moment to negotiate this out
but I know this current proposal and the
idea of billions of dollars for a wall
is unacceptable to me senator Booker
thank you so much for joining us thank
you